so as you know quarterdigital.com is a
cool website we also have son of a
dungeon that's on there and that's a
it's a really really great show we're
almost done with it the finale is coming
up it's coming out just after Halloween
and I mean Jordan's been doing great so
far but it seems that now that we're
hitting the Finish Line something's
happening he's slowing down and a lot of
shots that Jordan is supposed to do are
not done I don't know what's going on
with Jordan
there's a lot of red here and I'm just
seeing your name over and over again no
I get that I know it's it's coming up
it's a lot we're trying to get this
episode out this episode requires a lot
of work you know it's the biggest one
and uh
I mean we're almost at Halloween too
which isn't the best time do you go
trick-or-treating are you a child no you
shouldn't I mean I guess some people
view it as a as like a holiday like a
fun thing for me it's it's more of a day
to get through than to to enjoy at this
point so sorry I mean so you're telling
me that November 1st you're fine and
then November once we're through this
whole like season where I have to see
things on lawns that just bring bring it
all back like are you designing a
haunted house like is there a lot of
preparation or is this it's not so much
like organizing a haunted house as it is
navigating the haunted house in my head
hey Peter hey Peter hey Peter uh here
Jordan Allen he's dealing with some
stuff here it has something to do with
Halloween and some sort of deep-seated
drama that surrounds it you need me to
like pick up some shots or something I'm
thinking okay do you remember remember
when Clint came by he was stressed out
and I made this like cool relaxation
zone for him in VR yeah yeah that really
helped him I remember
please stop
on fire yeah it did really it actually
worked so I would love to see your take
on it since you're a VR developer now we
know we can heal through VR Clint wasn't
dealing with deep-seated trauma he was
just a little bit stressed out and we
just brought him to a point of
relaxation however Jordan is at a far
higher Peak here his fears are kind of
consuming him I think it's like the same
process we need to go through only and
now instead of just getting over some
stress we have to get over fears help
him relive those traumas in an effort to
get over them yeah relive the traumas in
a way that helps him overcome them and
not just makes it worse whatever he's
going through okay so I'm a little
worried because Sam has tasked me with
fixing Jordan I could either fix him
forever or damage him irreparably so I
need to be sure I know what I'm doing
how to do therapy at home
this is
seven tips on how best to do self
therapy start by thinking about what
you'd like to achieve
I want to fix Jordan understand more
about your problem or goal and I guess I
don't really understand that much about
what Jordan is going through maybe I
need to take my research off the
computer and put it onto Jordan
hello well Jordan thank you for coming
in today oh my goodness this is
incredible um tell me about how you're
feeling I'm feeling good yeah I'm I'm a
little anxious about what we might be
exploring I just want to be a better
version of myself I think coming out of
this than than I am going in
what's your biggest fear
oh
you mean like physical fear let's start
with Primal Fear
full frontal nudity really yes
but I have other fears too that are
probably better suited for YouTube is
the full frontal you're afraid of you
being full frontal or other people being
full frontal frontal to frontal and I
don't know if that stems from the locker
rooms
are you writing
when you're writing huh I
don't worry about it yeah I mean I I can
take you back to
my childhood you please if we want to
explore when I was a child we moved into
an apartment the day that I moved in
yeah
me and my brother never wanted to go
into our rooms it was always ice cold in
that room freaky the day that I moved in
I made a new imaginary friend oh I
called him Kevin in heaven I was three
years old you call him that you know I
don't know but I could describe him to a
tea with total accuracy every single
time I would describe him as like a
middle-aged gentleman in like a
three-piece tuxedo type outfit and I
started misbehaving the day we moved in
I started breaking things stealing
things and when confronted I would say
Kevin in heaven told me to do it but it
was only when I was older that it was
revealed that he might have not been
imaginary because the day we moved from
that apartment is the day I stopped
talking about Kevin in heaven
what you you feel like Kevin in heaven
might have been a ghost I might he might
have been a ghost he might have been a
ghost he might be the thing that I feel
pursuing me in dark hallways how are you
feeling right now
I'm feeling a bit exposed I might need
another pair of pants do we have another
pair of pants
we're gonna bring in some pants for you
yes just to make you feel thank you guys
now this this makes a difference just
the weight of the pants on your legs I
think yeah just knowing that there is
another layer there I hear you is is
enough for me to pers to continue this
yeah I had a pretty horrible dream I was
in the grocery store my local Vons and I
was shopping and I look up and there was
an old woman with long hair with her
back towards me at the end of the
grocery store aisle yeah so I thought
you know what I'm just gonna go to the
checkout and wrap this up and so I went
to the checkout and I was scanning my
items and I looked to my left and it's
the old woman but she's right next to me
in line that's so unsettling and she
turns and she has these wild bloodshot
eyes and she stabs me in the heart a
super spooky dog I might need another
pair of pants do we have another do we
have another Nick can we get yours can
you just throw them off safe safe you
look comfortable I can see it in your
eyes I've never felt more myself and let
me tell you I'm proud of you thank you
I'm really proud of you I think you're
ready for the next level in our next
session I'm going to have an experience
for you
I'm trying to think of a pun that uses
pants as thanks and I can't do it you're
coping so the therapy session with
Jordan was super helpful and honestly
there's so much to work with I'm also
scared of like Demons What kind of
demons the ones that get yeah you know
and this is great because it gives me
the opportunity to at multiple points
throughout the simulation try different
things attack different fears full
frontal nudity Kevin in heaven and
grocery store lady there will be a
specific game mechanic for each one I
see a circle right all woven together
into Jordan's story it needs to be
gamified he needs to be able to win this
thing we got a full body Avatar here so
if I move my hand in the real world and
there's something
in the game it says uh-uh could I spend
time to make this uh stable you know
that's not what's important here what's
important is the emotion oh where'd my
pants go
oh I've been working on a clothing
removing system which I've never done
before in code we have a full naked
Avatar we start out fully clothed and
then at any point in the simulation
Jordan himself can choose to take his
shirt and pull it off
and same thing with the pants
so that simple thing took way too long
to implement I think it's really
important that I get this right I care
about Jordan and it's going to be worth
it
Peter's gonna be here any minute now
we've been talking about doing this for
a couple weeks wait why are we doing
this on Halloween you know it's a little
bit drying because we had one therapy
session and I kind of just unloaded
everything onto him and then he just
kind of left and hasn't been responding
to my emails it's been like two weeks
now and I haven't heard back from him
and so I'm kind of stuck processing all
of this I haven't talked about Kevin and
Heaven in a long time when you bring
stuff down from the attic and you open
those boxes and then the therapist
leaves the house and doesn't help you
put the boxes away I think my chances of
being healed here are pretty low all
right today's the big day ready to go
everything's set and ready for Jordan I
just have to uh look who's calling
what's up man hey Peter I'm just
thinking like how can we take this to
the next level right how can we how can
we make it stand out and courtesy of
today's sponsor Squarespace I think I've
got the perfect ideas it took me a long
time to make this and new features would
take a while but what did you have in
mind you you've got a business model in
the palm of your hands right now and all
we need is a beautiful award-winning
template from Squarespace with
Squarespace we can create a website that
allows for all the things we need to
create a competent and efficient
business for VR experiences they've
already got members areas available for
us to build out wow yeah that means we
can create a paywall and bring in
clients we make it a Cooperative
experience Squarespace even allows you
to do appointment scheduling we we just
book everyone in and you know with top
of the game analytics we can see who's
coming to our website what they're doing
how they're utilizing our website and
that allows us to better tailor it to
give people and customers a better
experience that's amazing I'm getting
really excited about this yes dudes and
if you're interested in getting 10 off
of your first purchase of a website or
domain head on over to squarespace.com
Corridor crew to get started today thank
you and what was that discount code one
more time oh it's squarespace.com
Corridor crew or just click the link in
the description of this video for 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain okay great it was good talking to
you all right good talking to you and uh
say say hi to Jordan for me I will oh
I'm saying hi all right don't scare them
too much
uh so Peter you obviously have many
talents but from time to time you tend
to go above and beyond when it comes to
the scope of a project and when it comes
to a Reddit challenge that's great but
when it comes to quelling someone's
fears and helping them like get past
trauma over doing it we risk going too
far Sam we're on the bleeding edge here
I'm a little concerned what it might do
to him
me too man we'll see Pizza goes well I
mean me too
like we're here to like help him
look at that that's what we want that is
not scary not yet same you don't
understand this is a part of the story
where it's supposed to be a peaceful
moment this is I I haven't seen this at
all should I like test this out before
he does and like I I think yeah we're on
the precipice of wrapping this huge show
it's all coming down to Jordan to help
us get it done I'm trying to bring
Jordan back from the brink here I'm not
trying to shove him violently over the
edge I took the initiative to have you
create this and so ultimately I'm
accountable are you absolving me of
responsibility if his sanity meter drops
below zero I might have to blame you I
honestly have a feeling that this won't
be scary at all in fact it might just be
very confusing
Jordan has told you about his nightmares
and I'm about to experience them second
hand with no context
I
oh my God
if you're this scared I'm kind of
worried about Jordan This is
how could you do this to him there's a
lot to take in I'm not gonna lie
um
I don't like that you know actually yeah
I'm good all right so uh
I don't know man I just feel like I just
need another pair of pants I want to put
another pair of pants it's fine let's
find a bathroom I could buy these
because people can see these pants it's
like if I want to wear a couple pairs of
pants what's the big deal
thank you
this is legitimately frightening and I
can only imagine the fear he's going to
experience you asked me to do this I'm
like I've got you I have chills right
now that was so terrifying okay
shoot should we still go through with
this is this a good idea I might just
think for a bit I'm gonna do this
and if you can find a pair of pants
maybe yeah if we can just have something
yeah just
yeah
okay you got this
hey they're just lice they're just likes
just epidermis dog
everyone's got it well most people can
have it I think some people don't have
skin
we've made it this far
we carry through with this experiment
what have I done and just see what those
results are
hey
here to grow and change and I will say
on my drive here driving down the
freeway I'm feeling nervous and as I'm
like kind of losing my nerve kind of
wanting to turn around no joke it's
literally happened I see a guy stand up
out of the Bush no shirt or pants stands
up Victorious with confidence I've never
seen before and I want that I thought in
my head as I was driving I said I want
that I want that kind of mental Freedom
that kind of clarity to just boom just
be me I love the me that I am I don't
need lots of pants I know this it feels
oh it feels fine Jordan it's your task
to complete this experiment you got to
begin the healing let's do this me
shaking your hand I really hope it helps
you and I think it will okay are you
ready all right here we go
entering the simulation in three two one
Let The Healing begin
that's he this is here
I'm ready to I'm ready to face my fears
no it's me
ah dude
no
oh dude oh shoot
all right
no dude
thank you
foreign
[Music]
no
no
no get away from me
Jordan I wanna go up to heaven it's been
so long
uh I just want to go up there
I
need my bones
can you help me get my arm bones I need
them to fly yes yes please please
yes yes
oh
where are they
Kevin
oh my gosh
looks like it's beginning to work
what's up
don't look
oh hey hello Jordan it's nice to meet
you my name is
and this is
um and we just picked you up because we
uh we're doing a little research on
humans it's actually we're grad students
and uh we wanted to kind of do some
biology research on humans
um
because there isn't really much good and
anatomical uh diagrams for you guys okay
great just take off your clothes okay
you got it you got it you can do it no I
can't
there's cameras
I can do the shirt that's fine oh my God
okay great awesome yeah you look good
this is illegal oh yeah you look amazing
uh okay great yeah stand right here look
look at the camera oh man
I'm gonna regret this when I'm a parent
great all right now turn to the side if
you could oh you want a freaking profile
too
oh this feels weird dude
okay let's get kind of let's get a funny
one let's get a funny one all right okay
okay that'll do it okay thank you so
much for being a part of this you're
really helping us out I can sue you from
your brain activity that you you're
looking for some bones
um yeah we actually have a bone right
here
for Kevin it was great meeting you you
seem like a really cool guy and I hope
whatever this is goes well thank you um
all right we'll catch you later we're
just gonna drop you all right three two
one peace wow
that's kind of nice
very complimentary
oh frick I'm clothed again at least
this is where I
know
oh not this place no no oh oh damn it
it's right out of the freaking dream
no dude
go I can't run
oh
let me try again
just focus man it's okay
get to the checkout
oh dude she's not freaking looking at me
okay
all right how am I supposed to get out
of here
oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no
no
I can do this
I'm just gonna run for it
ah
ah
jeez gotta get the 20 trees I feel like
it's not on the cart
my list
oh we don't need anything from the store
Amazon same day
go go
conquer oh what
[Music]
I don't need you
I don't need groceries
hey
you're so hard
yeah
get out of here
[Music]
oh my gosh Jordan oh my God my arm bones
Kevin I can finally feel my fingers I've
been waiting for this for so long I've
been so sad all these years and now I'm
so happy and it's all thanks to you
thank you man hey I'm really proud of
you you showed your naked bod to those
aliens yeah that's incredible that's
real gross for you and punching that
scary lady man that took a lot of
Courage I really admire that but most of
all you gave me my own bones back yeah
and now I can fly up to heaven enjoy my
family yes man you have no idea how
appreciative I am I really love you man
I freaking deserve it man you deserve
arm bones and I'm gonna miss you but
it's time to go join my family get out
of here all right bud I'll see you later
hey word of advice show that naked
bottle a little bit more it's sexy okay
forget about it all right I'll see you
later bye-bye dude heck yeah
Kevin from Heaven is finally going to
heaven oh yeah it feels good baby this
story has a happy ending
hey hey Just for kicks you want to throw
those clothes off one more time
so healed he didn't even know he took
his clothes off
look at me
yeah look at the back too
[Music]
oh
all right
I think it worked oh I'm sweating so
much but I feel lighter than I've ever
felt
you did it I can't tell you how much
this means to me man you did it Bud oh
you did great
my heart you didn't try to get out of
that headset one time I knew this was it
was now or never for me I knew that and
I really appreciate you taking the time
I appreciate you watching it
yeah of course yeah often when you do
this a long time Sam you feel
comfortable now Sam I think we should
wrap this up it's time to find the
sanity meter it's honestly a good thing
and freed in VR and it's time to be free
in real life oh no Sam I want you to
look at me this is terrifying
what
what is going on
I don't need them anymore
thanks to you guys Peter
good job
thank you Sam that means a lot I came in
here today with three major fears that
was Kevin in heaven unresolved issues
regarding our relationship he's in
heaven again I have peace the old woman
in the aisle I beat the crap out of her
so I don't need to worry about that
anymore and nudity and I face those
aliens I posed in a funny pose for
photographs that we'll probably find
their way online I don't even care naked
and they complimented me all those
things are out of the way and I feel a
sense of renewal and I have all this
energy and I need somewhere to put it
and so I want to get back to what I love
I love visual effects I love pouring
into this stuff and working with you
guys and so if there's anything you need
me to do I'm here now well let's go have
a chat upstairs I got some spreadsheets
to show you
[Music]
are you here
things that are as tall as me that are
coming at me I notice you Flinch when
Jonah or Fenner
because Jonah's shorter than me yeah oh
okay only when he's in heels do I Flinch
but Fenner I'm constantly in this hyper
tense state if I'm also wearing pants
then I feel like I could do anything